c'est une porte comme tant d'autres sans
indication aucune mais elle mène vers un
autre monde un voyage au centre de la
terre nous sommes dans les catacombes de
dessin un réseau de tunnels souterrains
creusés au fil du temps par des
générations de mineurs qui ont laissé
leur trace
christine coste
igor grecque n'est jamais aussi heureux
que leur fils est sous terre
il n'était qu'un adolescent quand il y
est descendu pour la première fois
c'était il y à 42 ans un coup de foudre
j'étais curieux de découvrir ce qui se
trouve au delà du prochain virage dit il
et c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui de
ces reports on est intéressant une
passion devenue profession il est
aujourd'hui l'un des spéléologues les
plus en vue en ukraine
this model
connecteurs différentes pâtes profs
quand
igor connaît le réseau des catacombes
comme le fond de sa poche ses origines
ses multiples usages au fil du temps
le baccharis autres zones
situées à plus de 20 mètres sous la
surface les sous terrains contiennent
plusieurs bunkers construits au milieu
du siècle dernier pour se protéger des
bombardements
nasa banca
alors igor sait où aller en cas d'
attaques venues du ciel
les habitants des villes peuvent
s'installer ici à l'abri des bombes dit
il on peut y rester longtemps toute
sécurité des semences ainsi des deux
artistes android
c'est la raison qui a poussé alexander
sadovnikov aménager les catacombes prêt
chez lui en abris antiaériens
dès les premiers jours de la guerre il y
installer tout nécessaire à la survie
des gens du quartier nous décollons
sponso
on a mis des matelas ici pour s'asseoir
cécile il ya des casques et là un peu
d'eau potable
il a pensé à tout des chambres des
toilettes de la lumière et même internet
et puis tout près de l'entrée une grande
salle à manger loue des sources pour ce
cadre car doute les gens du quartier
descendez si lorsque sonne les sirènes
d'alert dit il
un abri très populaire selon alexander
il a accueilli récemment près de 300
personnes en même temps au poker tour du
court double ouvrir une torsion il
n'existe pas de cartographie officielle
des catacombes de dessin mais la légende
veut que le réseau soit long de
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres quoi
qu'il en soit une chose est claire en
cas de besoin une bonne partie de la
population pourrait se réfugier ici et y
rester très longtemps il si jean
françois bélanger radio-canada au dessin